6-Mute English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6-Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth.
Would you like some fried chicken and chips with gravy, Beth?
No, thanks, Neil. I don't really like fried chicken. It's too oily for me.
Okay, no problem. But maybe you'd like some organic poulé roti
in a tender meat jou with fried.
Oh, that sounds interesting. What is it?
Well, it's French for chicken and chips with gravy.
It's a strange fact, but the same dish described using different words can make it sound
more delicious, more exotic and more desirable.
Restaurants think carefully about the language they use to describe the food on their menus,
trying to make it sound appealing, tasty or poetic. Instead of hamburgers, we have gourmet burgers.
It's jou, not gravy. And raspberry coulis sounds a lot tastier than raspberry sauce.
Many of the words used to describe gourmet food. That's food which is higher quality
and more sophisticated than usual are French. Coming from a country with a long tradition of high
level cooking called oat cuisine. But how does the language use to describe food affect our
psychology and help restaurants make menus which are both tempting and profitable?
That's what we'll be finding out in this programme along with some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you, Neil. To train as a classical French chef takes months
as a full-time apprentice. But what is the name of the most famous cooking school teaching French
cuisine? Is it a, le cod om ble, b, le cod om rouge, or c, le cod om noir?
Well, I think it's le cod om ble. Okay, Neil. I'll reveal the correct answer later.
It's important for restaurants to describe items on the menu so diners know what to expect.
And many chefs think foreign words sound more exciting. But according to linguist Dr.
Kerry Matwick, the use of French is decreasing. Here, Kerry explains why to Ruth Alexander,
presenter of BBC World Service programme, The Food Chain.
Yeah, there are studies that show that because it sounds fancier. You know,
the French food has long been considered the gourmet food. And it was popular, but I would say
now there's a tendency to not use French because it sounds pretentious. So it can turn a dine or off.
Many restaurants use French names in menus because they sound fancy, an adjective meaning
special or unusual with lots of decoration. Kerry disagrees. She thinks French names used to be
popular, but are now seen as pretentious. If something is pretentious, it tries to appear more
important or clever than it really is. Some diners like the French names, but it turns other diners
off. If something turns you off, it makes you stop feeling interested or excited.
Brazilian chef Caroline Martins agrees that using French names in menus is becoming a thing of
the past. Caroline has stopped using French names in her pop-up restaurant, Samper, in Manchester,
as she explains to Ruth Alexander for BBC World Service programme The Food Chain.
I am classically trained in a French cuisine. I was using a lot of French terms, you know.
That wasn't very welcome. People would be very confused. They would ask me,
what is this Bruno Mars? What is this chiffonade? They would definitely avoid the dishes or they
would be sarcastic as well about it. I had people looking at the bus sitting down and then they
start seeing all these French terms and they just leave. Really? Yes. I had that happening.
You had people walking out to the restaurant. I just think this isn't for me. This is for me.
This is for me. What is this? What am I eating? I want to eat food. I don't want to eat
food. Not names, posh names. Instead of feeling excited about dishes described in French,
Caroline's diners were sarcastic about them. They mocked and made fun of them.
Some diners even walked out. Caroline thinks French makes her cooking sound too
posh, too fashionable, expensive and not available to everyone. She's now started using English and her
native Brazilian Portuguese on the menu and is pleased with the results. Customers don't feel
confused and their curiosity about the Brazilian dishes starts a conversation with the waiter.
All this talk of food is making me hungry, Neil. Anyway, it's time to reveal the answer to my
question. What's the name of the famous French cooking school that teaches Oat Quazine?
I said it was Le Corse en Blu. Was I right? Le Corse en Blu was the correct answer.
The famous culinary art school, Le Corse en Blu, first opened its doors in Paris in 1895.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary we've learnt from this programme starting with gourmet food,
which is better quality and more sophisticated than usual and is often more expensive.
The adjective fancy means special, unusual and decorative. If someone is pretentious,
they try to appear more important or clever than they really are.
The phrase to turn someone off means to make someone stop feeling interested or excited.
If you say something sarcastic, you mock and insult something by saying the opposite of what you
mean. And finally, the adjective posh means fashionable, smart, expensive and exclusive.
Once again, our six minutes are up. Join us again soon for more trending topics and useful
vocabulary here at six minute English. Goodbye for now. Bye!